- Just sitting at my desk at home
when I stabbed myself
with a pencil in my eye.
- I was in the first grade,
and I was six years old.
- Second grade.
- Probably the third grade.
- Third grade or fourth grade.
- I was in seventh grade.
- This is the first time
I've told this story
because it just doesn't
come up that often.
- My friend and I had been
messing around a little bit,
and I had elbowed him in the leg.
So, we were sitting in the wood shop
with a very attentive teacher.
As soon as he turned around, my buddy
took his mechanical
pencil and just kind of
gave me a quick jab in the thigh.
- So I was walking to one of my classes.
In our school, there was
brick wall everywhere.
And I had my pencil in my hand.
I was dragging it along the brick wall.
And it got wedged in between a brick,
and then the pencil
went right into my hand.
- I was sitting at the kitchen table,
and I was coloring.
And I like to take a regular pencil first.
And I was erasing, and it jabbed right in.
It got lodged right in there,
and I started to scream
'cause it hurts really, really, really bad
when you get anything
in between your fingers.
I thought I was gonna get lead poisoning
'cause I didn't understand
that it's not poisonous.
- My younger brother and
I were farting around
in the living room.
And I don't know why, but
he had sharpened a pencil,
tossed willy-nilly onto the floor.
And I'm running around
without my shoes on.
Step on it, crack, ugh.
It had stuck into the
bottom of my left foot.
And I tried to get it out.
The more I tried to dig it out,
the further it seemed to
enmesh itself with my flesh.
- I was just sitting at my desk at home.
And I must have just erasing
something really vigorously,
gesturing a little bit
too hard, and it went
straight into my eye.
I just immediately started freaking out
'cause I could see the
mark it left in my eye.
And I was like, "Oh, my
God, am I gonna go blind?"
- People have totally
noticed it without me
sharing the information because it's like
in the center of my right hand.
There is a black dot.
It's buried under my skin.
- Now it's just a part of me.
I'm kind of a cyborg in that sense.
- It's actually funny because
I'm the type of person
that has never broken any sort of bone.
So now that I think of
it, this is probably
the worst battle scar I honestly have
is just this thing in my eye
from stabbing myself with a pencil.
- I just hope somebody out
there can hear my story
and feel better about
their pencil stabbing.
- So for anyone who thinks that
they're alone in this world
with their pencil scars, you're not.
- There are a lot of us out there.
And if you ever feel lonely,
you can probably find
support on an internet forum.
I'm sure they exist.
- You should wear it proudly.
And just show that you
can move on from this.
- Or just find me on Twitter,
and I'll commiserate.